all right Samantha how old are you 24 24
years old from st. Louis paid off 43
thousand dollars in that in 16 months
count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream three two
one
I'm tax free
yeah
this is how it's done Wow
congratulations now some of you are out
there and you make twice what she makes
and you're still sucking your thumb and
whining in your 48 twice her age she
just rubs your nose in it she just
destroyed your whining
24 years old paid off 43 thousand
dollars and 16 months that's known as a
rock star I mean that young lady is on
fire Wow now maybe you're not just out
of school maybe you're not a civil
engineer I don't know maybe you got big
problems well welcome to the human that
blame race we've all got something to
get over don't we so you're gonna get
over yours this is your time this is
your time there is no excuse for you not
to start being intentional with your
income some of you've been slopping it
up half but doing stuff ition your way
along Dave ish financial peace ish and
and there's just no excuse for it
there's no excuse for it the verdict is
in this stuff works when you work it but
if you ich it you're gonna get ich
results and I gotta tell you I mean our
last two debt free screams last hour
this hour are both young people that are
dialed in they got a plan and they found
the plan and they're gonna stick to it
as a good friend of mine who's a
multimillionaire told me long ago David
I finally got out of that I decided I
was gonna submit to your way of thinking
you have to submit to something you're
gonna you know what it was all song
you're gonna serve somebody right you're
gonna serve something you're gonna serve
somebody you can assert Bank of
Americans
Motors and Sally may the rest your
dad-blame life if you keep itching along
that's just stupid it's lazy and it's a
lack of diligence and it's a lack of
emotional strength and courage on your
part you can do this I know you can
probably a whole lot more than some of
you no you can't because the shortest
distance between you and wealth is
getting rid of your stupid payments when
you don't have any payments you know
what you've got money the borrower is
slave to the lender that's why they call
it master card take a minute think about
your future
what if you never had another car
payment what if you never had another
credit card bill what if you got rid of
that student loan that's been around so
long you think it's a pet what if you
actually started to understand how
mutual funds and Roth IRAs and 401ks
work and you started using them to your
advantage
oh you got to be careful you'll be
thinking like one of those evil rich
people then well you can do all this
stuff Financial Peace University our
nine week class will show you how and
when you go the nine week class we give
you a one-year membership to financial
peace the entire online experience which
has the entire nine week class on it
online and it has the legacy journey
class afterward and it has the smart
money smart kids class and it has every
dollar plus and it has all kinds of
community for you to get involved and
get encouraged you learn how to spend
wisely how to get out of debt how to
save and pay cash for things so you
don't go back in debt get that emergency
fund in place walk your baby steps and
becoming every day millionaire we're
gonna show you how why do you want to do
that so you can retire with dignity so
you can change your family tree you
could be the last one in your branch of
the family tree that says I'm broke
little man can't get ahead he or is my
spirit animal you can stop that crap get
into Financial Peace University right
now go to Dave Ramsey comm get lined up
and you can have what Samantha's got
it's doable